الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع يؤكدان
الالتزام بالهدنه
وتحذيرات من انهيار الاقتصاد والاوضاع
المعيشيه في السودان
روسيا تصدر اطول حكم بالسجن على معارض
لبوتين
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
مع دخول الازمه في السودان يومها الرابع
اعلنت كل من الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع التزامهما بالهدنه المعلنه اليوم
بعد وساطه دوليه عضو مجلس السياده
الانتقالي شمس الدين كباشي قال في مقابله
مع العربيه ان الجيش وافق على هدنه مؤقته
لمده 24 ساعه اقترحتها البعثه الامميه في
الخرطوم وعدد من الدول بينها الولايات
المتحده مضيفا انها ستكون لتامين خدمه
المدنيين وتلبيه الاحتياجات المعيشيه
والطبيه اما الدعم السريع فاكد للعربيه
على لسان يوسف عزت المستشاري السياسي
لحماتي انه لا اعتراض على الهدنه وان
قواتهم ستلتزم بشكل كامل
انسانيا واقتصاديا جاءت الاشتباكات
الحاليه لتزيد من الوضع المعيشي المتازم
للسودانيين حيث حذر البنك الدولي من ازمه
اقتصاديه محتمله في البلاد التي تواجه مره
اخرى الصراع الى جانب المخاطر المستمره
للكوارث الطبيعيه والضغوط الاقتصاديه
بدورها حضرت وكالات الاغاثه من ارتفاع
مستويات الجوع وتدهور الوضع الصحي في
السودان
وقالت انه سيكون من المستحيل تقديم
الخدمات الانسانيه في العاصمه الخرطوم وما
حولها في حال استمرار العمليات القتاليه
في وقت هرع المواطنين لشراء كميات كبيره
من السلع الغذائيه وتخزينها تحسبا لطول
امد الاشتباكات
الى روسيا الان وفي اطول فتره سجن بحق
معارض لبوتين حكم على الناشط السياسي
الروسي المعارض فلاديمير كارمورزا
بالسجنيه 25 عاما لاتهامات تتعلق بالخيانه
ونشر معلومات كاذبه عن الجيش الروسي
والانتماء الى منظمه غير مرغوب فيها وفق
المحكمه الروسيه العليا وفيما لم يستغرق
القاضي سوى دقائق لنطق الحكم في قضيه
كارمورزا هي عمليه عاده تستغرق وقتا طويلا
في المحاكم الروسيه اعزت الحكومه
البريطانيه سجنه الى دوافع سياسيه واستدعت
السفير الروسي لتقديم احتجاج
تنفيذا لبعض كان اطلقه سابقا كشف
الملياردير الامريكي ايلون ماسك رسميا عن
خطته لطرح منافس جديد لتطبيق الذكاء
الاصطناعي
في مقابله مع فوكس نيوز انه بدا فعلا في
تاسيس شركته الخاصه بالذكاء الاصطناعي
التوليدي ووصفها بانها ستكون خيارا قويا
يتحدث تطبيقات المنافسات رغم اقراره بان
المنافسه ستكون كبيره مع بقيه التطبيقات
الذكيه كونه بدا متاخرا في هذا المجال في
ايام ماسك مشروعه الجديد تروس
خبرنا الاخير ايضا من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ففي حادث جديد يتعلق بظاهره
انتشار الاسلحه بين السكان اطلق رجل
امريكي يبلغ من العمر 84 عاما النار على
فتى من اصول افريقيه لم يتجاوز من العمر
16 عاما بعد ان الطرق الاخير باب منزله
بالخصاء الشرطه الامريكيه قالت ان الفتى
تلقى الرصاصات في راسه وذراعه لكنه نجا من
الموت باعجوبه بعد ان تم نقله بسرعه
للمستشفى فيما قال المدعي العام الامريكي
ان اطلاق النار كان ذو خلفيه عنصريه بسبب
لون بشرات الفتى لكن
لم يتهم بارتكاب جريمه كراهيه ولم يصنفه
تقرير الشرطه بانه متحيز عنصري